we've covered the many many flip-flops
and reversals and back and forth on
countless issues by president-elect
Donald Trump this includes Obamacare
this includes deportation forces this
includes punishment for women who have
abortions and everything in between
one thing that I have to credit Donald
Trump with and I said it on the show
yesterday he has been very consistent
about liking strongman authoritarian
dictators of all kinds he praised blad
amir putin during the presidential
campaign he had this weird sort of
indirect praise for North Korean leader
Kim jong-un he had praise for
authoritarian extremists
turkish President Erdogan for quote
turning the coup around a coup that has
been debunked as actually even being a
real coup attempt he has reportedly
recently told as I discussed with you
yesterday Filipino president Rodrigo
Duterte that he supports his violent
vigilante murder campaign against not
convicted but suspected drug dealers and
drug addicts and he said many times
during the 2016 presidential campaign
and before that while Saddam Hussein was
a quote bad guy he did praise Saddam
Hussein for being an efficient killer of
terrorists not totally untrue but not
exactly the type of thing you want to be
saying while running for president of
the United States well we have now heard
from former Iraqi leader Saddam
Hussein's daughter regard Hussein and
she has praised Donald Trump apparently
some of the fondness here goes both ways
let's take a look at a recent quote to
CNN from regatta who saying who said
this man has just arrived to the
leadership but from what is apparent
this man has a high level of political
sensibility that is vastly different
than the one who preceded him he exposed
the mistakes of the others specifically
in terms of Iraq which means he is very
aware of the mistakes made in Iraq and
what happened to my father
Trump exposed the mistakes of Iraq no
Trump
a very coy way of self-aggrandizing
himself and his foresight through
campaign propaganda and that seems to
have actually worked on saddam hussein's
daughter trump kept saying during the
campaign i've always been against the
war in iraq well that was demonstrative
demonstrably untrue as we expose during
the campaign we also have exposed that
donald trump is totally clueless on
Middle East policy the guy doesn't know
anything at all
and I as I as I read about this I was
fascinated that not only did Trumpets
who ended up voting for Trump American
citizens fall for Trump simplistic
propaganda on so many of these issues
even Saddam Hussein's daughter seems to
have fallen for Trump's pop propaganda
force she can't vote in the United
States unless you believe Trump that
tons of people who aren't authorized to
vote in the US voted for Hillary Clinton
although it sounds like regard Hussein
would have more likely voted for Donald
Trump there's one other similarity I
noticed actually between Donald Trump
and Saddam Hussein which is if you've
seen the recent pictures of Trump's
Trump Tower penthouse apartment Trump
and Saddam Hussein both seem to share a
very strong predilection for gold-plated
furniture and gold on absolutely
anything that you can put it on so the
back-and-forth continues two-way
fondness between Donald Trump and the
associates of and actual authoritarian
strongmen dictators uh and no exception
here yet another one and I'm still
waiting to see when Rodrigo Duterte is
going to show up at the White House and
maybe reminisce with Donald Trump about
when he personally would get on a
motorcycle and go kill suspected drug
dealers as mayor of Davao in the
Philippines